una protesta en forma de bloqueo es la
imagen que se ha registrado en 14 de los
26 estados de Brasil desde la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones generales del
domingo en las que el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio urólada Silva se impuso al
presidente Yair bolsonaro por menos de
dos puntos porcentuales Aunque Los
Seguidores de evolucionaron siguen
rechazando el resultado de las urnas
este miércoles el mandatario calificó
esta manifestación como ilegítima tener
las carreteras cerradas está afectando a
todos el llamado que les hago es
desbloqueen las carreteras protesten de
otra manera y en otros lugares porque
esto es bienvenido y hace parte de la
democracia
bolsonaro apela a la economía para hacer
este llamado y aunque entre el martes y
el miércoles las localidades afectadas
por los bloqueos pasaron de 190 a 126
efectivamente han aparecido protestas de
otra manera
tanto en Sao Paulo como en Río de
Janeiro ha habido manifestaciones frente
a comandos militares para pedir la
intervención de los uniformados en lo
que aseguran es un Llamado de emergencia
estamos aquí
enfrente del Comando este militar
pidiendo los generales que nos ayuden la
gente está haciendo lo que puede estamos
en nuestro límite general Socorro
bolsionaron un antiguo militar
nostálgico de la dictadura no cargó
contra estas protestas en su mensaje del
miércoles imágenes de un país polarizado
en medio de una transición que se
muestra conflictiva y aún sin un
reconocimiento de derrota claro por
parte del presidente saliente